ladies and gentlemen director Angel
Manuel Soto
hello how are you doing sir I'm doing
good I'm doing good
um not as tired as I thought it would be
uh what is it like normally without a
strike you have a cast to help promote
something so what the hell has it been
like being the one who has to get out
there and like talk to everyone
um it's it's uh it's been intense uh
I don't like to be in front of the
cameras like I don't mind having these
conversations like I like it but being
in front of the camera
for hours and hours and hours and then
having to travel
like it's cool to travel but it's it's
cool to go places it's not it's not cool
to travel
like it gets very tiresome after a while
on on the jet lag and the hour changes
and usually for me it's more like
emotional weight yes you get physical
extortion and depends who you interview
with it's it's kind of like exciting uh
I'm being a different location different
places different cultures I always it
feels cool but it's like like that whole
understanding that um you know this this
moment for me uh I would have loved that
for them to experience it you know
because you never get a chance I mean we
rarely get a chance to to to be
leading movies much less be leading
superhero movies
um and for me like
them being taken away from that
opportunity is the one thing that kind
of like weighs on me but at the same
time I'm constantly reminded that one is
not about me and two they're doing
you know they're fighting the good fight
so uh
I have to step up for them uh because
they deserve it and what they're doing
right now and I've said it a bunch of
times I'll say it till the very end
sacrificing this opportunity that
they're having of being front and
centered uh
to make sure that actors and writers
have a better pay and better treatment
it's a heroic act in itself so
um I will always support them and I just
hope people understand that and show up
and support them too
what is it like I can't imagine what
it's like when you see someone right
there who is a kid dressed up as Blue
Beetle and I mean because it's all cool
that we're all enjoying the movie but
ultimately what is it like for you as a
filmmaker seeing kids where it means so
much to them well man like for me as
much you know as an adult and and as a
consumer of Cinema cinephile of course I
love all types of movies uh I consume it
all the good the bad the ugly
um there's a place for everything in the
world and I hope everything exists
um but we did this movie for him you
know I did this movie because I never
had a movie like this done for me
um you know with people that look like
me being Heroes of their own stories so
seeing that his dream his vest up do you
like it
and he liked it you know like I I wanted
to my my other movies are for adults and
I wanted to make a movie that my nephews
and nieces can see and I can entertain
them and and you know in in the Latino
aspect of it that they can see
themselves represented as Heroes because
I never got that chance not only to see
myself as a hero or somebody from my
community as a hero
um because you know besides being
vilified in Hollywood for such a long
time and politically and culturally
um our stories have never been told
honestly and they have never been told
in mainstream Hollywood by people like
us so having the thing that has a writer
director actors a lot of the crew or
Latino we were able to kind of like
protect and tell the stories the way
we're going to tell these stories
um
like we make fun of our own stereotypes
but we make fun of it not you you know
like it's up to us to make fun of
ourselves and and we want to have that
type of fun and show the world that we
can be fun we can we can take all the
Nostalgia and make a throwback movie and
put ourselves in situations that are
both fun and exciting and exhilarating
and and enjoy life and seeing that a kid
like that is able to witness that too
and like it until his friends and dress
up like libido
um
you only think of that when I made that
movie I didn't know what that could be a
possibility I know that that happens but
that's never happened for a product that
I've done so seeing that is surreal so
we we're screening here at IMAX
headquarters in IMAX and I really want
to give the a huge thank you to is for
partnering up 100 you know um so what is
it like for you because this is your
first IMAX film uh yes so what was like
was this the theater that you were
checking it out yeah this is the theater
that I that I kissed on
um I was super excited to see because we
wanted it to be on IMAX we wanted to
um even from the get-go when they said
like oh wanna do theatrical yeah well
theatrical people want to be in IMAX
like this the screen is ridiculous you
know like this whole top to bottom thing
for me is very impressive uh and you
know we just recently got Cinemas like
this in Puerto Rico and the first time
that I witnessed an IMAX theater was
like
I think I had to see the movie twice
because I was just blown away by being
able to look at everything for the first
time so immersive so we really wanted it
to be that way and we really wanted to
tap into it and not just go for the
streaming I know that film will end up
in streaming and that's fine but you
know
it was a disadvantage for us at the
first one we were like man finally we
got a superhero that that is Latino and
they're sending us to streaming and the
fact that we were able to convince them
otherwise and deliver a film for IMAX is
it's amazing it's like another thing
that I wasn't expecting it wasn't in my
bingo cards and the fact that it could
happen and that is happening and we got
the iMac support is is really impressive
for me yeah what was that I actually
want to go back in time a little bit and
when you first went in to meet with
Warner Brothers talk a little bit about
walking in and uh pitching them and
because I'm sure you were not the first
choice of one maybe you were I don't
know but like what was it like pitching
the studio and in getting a project like
this because it's a big budget it's a
big film it's you know it's a big step
forward for your career also so
um there's something that I learned with
DC and is that
um
you don't pitch this they say it pitches
you
um and and that was really
another thing I was not expecting
because I've been pitching you know I I
did La Granja in Puerto Rico I did Charm
City Kings afterwards here uh but I've
been pitching for like 40 50 projects
you know like only one Fair only one
came through which was some City games
and after that when we were gonna go to
theaters after the primary Sundance
um the pandemic hit so we were all in
lockdown I was I was in lockdown in
Puerto Rico and during that whole
quarantine process one of the executives
of of the sea Galen Wiseman saw Charm
City Kings and he loved it he loved like
the the authenticity of the culture of
the environment he loved that the heart
that he had and how much care I put into
my characters which is what I love to do
um and they enjoyed the the the the the
the chase sequence that the film has in
the middle of the movie uh and I get a
call from the sea
um and I thought it was a general
meeting but it was actually they were
gonna pitch me something and I went in
and I went into pitch Bane because I
wanted to make and I still want to make
an origin story about Bane I think
I see a couple knots yeah you know it's
cool yeah uh
and then they were like yeah that's cool
but you know that whole thing belongs to
Matt Reeves
I'm like okay
but we got something for you Blue Beetle
and that's how it started they pitched
me Blue Beetle and at first I was
hesitant because
I didn't want a brown watch Spider-Man
you know I didn't want to uh
fall into the tropes of the same
rhetoric that Hollywood keeps
perpetuating about Latinos and and they
were like no no you have to read the
script it's written by Gareth and he's a
Mexican from queretaro and
you know
you read it so when I read it that's
that's what I got convinced because it
had all the authenticity that only
somebody from that from that Community
from our community would actually
understand and I realized right there
that you know the the story of Blue
Beetle and the representation was in
good hands so I was wrong you were the
first choice I was the first choice
right I'm eating some [__] okay anyway
so what do you think would surprise
people to learn about making a big DC
movie I guess the bigger the project and
the bigger the IP the less control you
have
um
that that is a fact
yeah
it you would think it gets easier it
doesn't get easier literally More Money
More Problems and that's like very
literal in the whole process of the
filmmaking side but the one thing that I
did appreciate from
having a product like this is that
if you hire people around you that that
believe in the project people that
they're not just after a paycheck but
they actually read the script and they
connected to the story
uh in each of the Departments
you you realize really quickly that they
will have your back
at the end of the day and it's easier
for you to learn how to
delegate a lot of the things that in an
in a more Indie movie you have to like
take to yourself
um or being more in charge or Hands-On
during that pre-production process
you're able to communicate your vision
and get it so tight-knit that at the end
of the day they're able to protect you
to to be in charge of the things they
have to do so that I can focus on the
things that I care about and I can focus
on that you know my indispensibility of
character first and be protective of my
actors so that they can be in that
emotional state that physical spiritual
state to get that performances that I
want to get so it does help to be able
to have a solid team that has your back
and that comes out with you know with a
bigger budget for sure uh yeah I mean
I've spoken to so many filmmakers that
say if you make something for 10 million
you have a lot of control and once you
every 10 million above it's this is
losing and losing and losing control and
yeah at the end of the day you know it's
a
you're it's like working with a client
like I do commercials for a long time
and I think that that did prepared me
for the relationship that comes with
working uh with a studio this big and
with a project this big is that at the
end of the day you're directing it but
is there a movie 100 so what is
something that you really fought for
that you got in the movie that you're
really happy it worked out the car packs
flashback
the the villains flashback for me was
very important to
humanize this villain
um
to show because if
it is true that most times the Latino
representation in movies is often we're
often introduced in the middle of the
paragraph right where gangsters were
narcos were this where that our
community is sorry
you know um dangerous or whatever and we
have never had the opportunity to to
explore what led to them you know it's
always meant to to feel like they're
born that way that's who they are you
know and that's not true I'm not saying
that that doesn't exist but that is not
the reality that informs who we are so
with a villain that from the top there's
you know his ruthless and his
motivations or or X or Y I wanted to
create a
to not follow through
with with
his final blow
um and create that compassion we wanted
to create this moment of like peeling up
the layers and getting to the root of
the trauma
to understand that this person has his
trauma has been weaponized
and in order to create that the
flashback tells the story of uh of this
child shoulder and how this region which
includes also the Caribbean region
um has been consistently interfered
by Imperial powers and have no that's
what are the blood history modern blood
history is born is by the
consistent interference from
you know American imperialization and
trying to take over resources and and
staging Coupes and putting puppet
dictators to protect the interest of
American companies so Dia in this case
the school of the Americas which is a
historical fact
I didn't want this to fall into the
fallacies or into a a construct of
fantasy I wanted to show that even
though this is a fantasy movie uh there
is a reality a reality that exists that
is often overlooked or ignored from the
history books
because it is a dark part of what the
U.S has done in Latin America and I
really wanted to explore that's why even
on the flashbacks we intercut history
with archival footage of the school of
the Americas if anybody had doubts that
it was fake
um to create this sort of connection
given the fact that we haven't been able
to tell that story in mainstream Cinema
so that was very important for me to do
because one it it creates right there's
the plot aspect it tells the story of
how Victoria court has been involved in
the weaponization of this drama from the
beginning it also develops this
um
therapy Vibes of reaching into the core
of trauma in order to create compassion
for a villain and to understand why
Jaime made that decision and to actually
feel like at the end of the day
yes he still has to pay for his sins but
he can be assault to the sacrifice and
the third layer of that threat is to
create a historical context of one of
the many things that affects Latin
America and how that can play into the
big part of the story there's so many
things I want to talk about I'm thinking
about what I want to do next let's talk
about the fact that you got to put in uh
for people who maybe saw it the
establishing shot you got to put in Lex
Corp I'm going to something lighter from
what we were just talking about but you
get to include the Daily Planet DC nods
what does that mean to you and were
there any things talk about some of the
Easter eggs that maybe people should
look out for the next time they watch
and were there any Easter eggs you
wanted to do that uh Warner Brothers or
DC were like no chance yeah so we wanted
to make this uh it is a a very uh
contained story it is a new city for
this universe for the DC uh Cinematic
Universe and we really wanted to make
feel like yes it is its own thing but it
still lives in the bigger construct of
the DC Universe and the same way that
you know a lot of these Mega
corporations have
um
I don't know like they're they're in
every city
uh we wanted to show the same thing you
know like Lex Corp exists like all these
companies exist in in the bigger uh in
this uh I was like a globalized market
for a better work
um and that's some of the knots that
exist in the movie um we also have uh
you know heimla makes reference that I
can fly Superman can fly like there is
an awareness that these people exist
they just
not yet not yet not yet because once
they find out that a Mexican kid from a
poor neighborhood has a weapon of mass
destruction I'm sure they're gonna come
after him
um but uh exactly
I'm sure I'm sure the bug layer is
tapped and surveilled by Batman
but um the other part that we were
having fun with
um there is uh when when they're waking
Jaime up with the vix Vapor Rub
um
the the newscast is in Spanish but is
talking about Bruce Wayne
um
I don't know you have to pay attention
to everything like the the billionaire
playboy Bruce Wayne just bought
the dating app
for 66 billion dollars just like making
fun of what Elon Musk a little bit
um
but there's there's more uh at the
beginning of the title sequence for
those of you guys that follow the Blue
Beetle uh Comics there is a green light
that hits this carrot and that's a Green
Lantern
um if you didn't catch it watch it again
I guess I think
um also uh on the on the bug layer uh
and you'll see it also at the end
there's like a like a stack of Oreos
you know
exactly so maybe he was around who knows
with something like that do you think
that DC realized what you're doing or do
you think it snuck through
no
[Music]
they just that was part of the set
design you know right nobody asked right
let's go
the stuff that we wanted to do um
part of the technology that was being
developed from core Industries when we
were starting to design it we we wanted
to also be part of
um of the way the technology develops
for Deathstroke for example
um we wanted to
in the in in the vanity or in the
display box in court Industries some of
the stuff that we wanted there we wanted
to have like a Kryptonite bullet we
wanted to have like a a Flash helmet
like we just wanted to give some nuts
like core Industries has had a part into
the bigger lore of um of of DC uh and
those were the ones that were like nope
nope uh the movie is about two hours and
seven minutes or so with credits with
credits uh I know you told me previously
that you needed to make a two-hour movie
if you what was your like director's cut
that you first submitted to the studio
like was it like two and a half 220 like
what was it no it was 217.
and was that like 10 minutes of footage
that you were like super happy with or
is that like fluff that you knew was
going to come out uh it had fluff it had
some fluff I knew that I still needed to
trim some fat of that director's cut
um and I did we did a version where I
went in and I did that trimming and it
ended up being like 206 207 like it
wasn't that much longer but they really
wanted it to be two hours so a lot of
some of the fighter sequences had to be
turned down
um
pacing wise Rhythm wise you had to be
like rushed in some of the moments
um
and in the beginning like there's a lot
of
um there were a lot of conversations
around the the gentrification of the
edge keys and how that's affecting them
more explicitly like so there was more
conversations about what the family is
facing directly
through the displacements of the locals
because of core properties keeps buying
people out
um and there was once in the act like I
said before some action sequences needed
to be cut down
um there was like this
um at the end this big Showdown
uh between car packs and and Jaime
where Jaime is like losing it and he's
like getting drunker and drunker with
rage and and kajida is trying to stop
him but he doesn't let he and then he
ended up pummeling him so there's like a
shunt there that that's not there
anymore
and one beautiful scene where uh the
family is having a really nice moment
outside of the house while Rudy is
fixing the chapulin
um
uh while he's fixing it there's like a
really enduring moment and Jenny is
witnessing this beautiful Dynamic of the
family uh which makes her kind of like
long for that I know we're here to
promote the theater but that's going to
be have a Blu-ray maybe I don't know I
was just going to ask you like uh well
hopefully well your fans will be able to
see that kind of stuff I would love that
I would love that they're they're very
beautiful scenes I'm really I mean I'm
really exciting uh set pieces too
you know maybe we'll save some for the
sequel exactly well the other thing
though is that that's the way you get
people to also you know buy a Blu-Ray is
including stuff that you can only you
know get on that thing so um talk a
little bit about the visual style of the
movie how you maybe wanted certain
colors to represent certain things or
the music or just like you know what I
mean talk about that those kind of
things that the director puts their hand
prints on yeah no like uh as far as like
the look and feel of it we really wanted
to hone in on the on the Nostalgia
Factor we wanted to feel
um familiar in a way that feels closely
and nostalgic
um we wanted to recreate this Neo Tokyo
essence of Palmetto City uh and you have
like all these like highlighting glossy
elements on the more metropolitan areas
that feel more uh fish you know
futuristic but at the same time when you
go to the Barrios we wanted to like
really live into the the the soil Vapor
the warmth the the the community aspect
of it we wanted that part of the house
and the community to feel like a warm
welcome like a warm soup in a cold night
uh versus everything else that feels a
little bit more
um
uh stylized and even like when you go to
like the villains uh like the the
Victoria's house or like the court
building there's like a sterile aspect
to it like a hyper clean there's not at
all trying to be anything more than just
sterile like
her soul
um and then you kind of like go against
you go inside the the Victoria's house
and then you go inside the Reyes house
and you can feel like there is a warmth
in the race house as a contrast to the
the the villain
um and as far as like the music like we
wanted the score to feel
um like that Tangerine dreams energy
that I miss so much and that I grew up
with and see how that kind of like fits
into the superhero genre and how those
sounds give you like those miami-esque
ladies uh retro synced wave sounds
um
just to shift it a little bit because we
wanted to we wanted it to feel cool but
the stuff that they listen uh is very
much more it's very more it's very much
spanning from
within a play I did a playlist coming
into a project that it would be like
what would be each of the songs that
each family member would have on their
phones and let's create that playlist
and let's tell the story of not just
Legacy of of of of of music that they
would listen from old songs that are
Regional to Mexican heritage or uh but
also like you know we we make punk music
in Latin America we make 80s music in
Latin America we make all and we consume
uh uh American music too from monthly
crew and you know we wanted to make a
plethora because we consume everything
we're not one particular thing so we
wanted to feel like there they exist in
the real world they don't exist in the
village far away they exist and even if
they exist in a village for a way they
consume this too like I listen to the
music living in a small island in the
Caribbean so it's kind of like how can
we open ourselves to the world and I
think the best way is understanding that
we also consume pop culture and we like
it and we hear it and we can have fun
with it too which shot or sequence I'm
switching to a different subject which
shot or sequence in the movie was like
the effin backbreaker
um
two
one was just conceptually and the fact
that we were dealing with somebody that
wasn't there who had covered and then we
got him the next day so we had to like
shoot around him and it was one of the
first things we shot with everybody not
just the families like the whole family
and Jenny cord uh which is when
um when they come back and he shows his
back and she's kind of like telling them
the exposition of the Scarab and Rudy
throws he really goes on his rant
um that scene took a long time and
because it's so chaotic because
everybody in the family is talking all
over each other everybody has something
to say somebody's moving spacing
it was intense to shoot and because we
were so limited with time you know we
shot this movie in 57 days like uh yeah
for people that don't realize it's not a
lot of time yeah
romantic comedy takes longer
um so we have to shoot this movie in a
short amount of time so so getting that
scene working
it took that that was I probably
probably was the the thing that took the
longest to edit to get it right it was
fun because we we developed this thing
um where we we should described
and then we have one fancy
we call it the fancy one where everybody
can do whatever they want they can have
fun they can joke and whatnot and that's
where George Lopez drives
uh so that that rant you know we only
had one line in the script and we just
had the camera there and he gave like a
seven minute improv rant of all the
different things that court is doing to
the community
uh and for like the
I mean it it went crazy like stop it
couldn't be there but it was fun too it
was fun like on on the first uh friends
and family screening when the movie was
like two hours and 40 minutes long we'll
play the whole thing just to like hear
the ones that people are laughing and
connecting with uh so we left three in
it
um is there any chance you're gonna
release that whole thing online it
should yeah you should I should
it was funny man like he I mean the one
with the testicles he made that up
and that the reaction is exactly the
reaction that you're like
because I don't like don't laugh don't
break like you can laugh but don't don't
really laugh you know like try to keep
it because if you react and the reaction
that Bruno gives is like
that was real
um but the other one that that the one
that really hurt my back like it's a
backbreaker
um was the the greatest house attack
because that a lot of this movements the
action sequences are done by a second
unit
um but that scene in particular we did
it the first unit and and for me was
very important because it's not just an
action sequence it's not just a raid
it's actually that feeling of dread and
impotence that a family might feel when
they're being
um
evicted or when they're being you know
deported that that fear of losing
everything that you have worked so hard
uh that you're holding it by a thread
I know the certain
some external forces are coming and
they're taking it away from you like the
separation of the families like all that
stuff and the Heart like the dad doesn't
die because there was an accident and
something fell off him he dies because
of all the stress of witnessing
everything he has built getting lost I'm
not being able to do anything about it
and that was like a very it wasn't
intense because that took a couple days
to shoot
but it was also a very emotionally
draining sequence uh especially like the
the system Milagro like the Wailing and
the crying and it was like
this is like the tone down version like
it was way more intense on visceral
um on the longer version but you know we
didn't it it kind of like it took you
from everything else because he was like
oh my gosh like I don't know if I could
have recorded for this there was no joke
that could recover from that version
sure but I want to go further on that
was he always the one who was going to
die or was there um the possibility of
another character in the film not making
it really
um
nobody was gonna die in the movie
that was like originally but you know
the studio kept pushing and convinced us
eventually like
you know how can we create a lowest of
lows
with the family member and how
how that low is not just another death
in the superhero genre but how about low
actually ends up being a power for him
right at the end of the day like what is
that push that this reluctantly rule
needs at the end of the day for you to
learn Grace's Destiny and and when we
started to understand that and we were
like man that could be a meander writer
we're like well this could be maybe a
good opportunity to explore magic
realism
um in this in this sequence where
he's about to die Jaime is about to die
um you know that's that's the metaphor
he he his vision of like the limbo or
heaven or Earth or whatever you want to
call it
um
is his house right like heaven is this
construct of the thing you feel like
it's home and this home starts to break
apart that's like the ticking clock of
like you have to make a decision time is
running out if you don't make the
decision you're gonna die
um so while all of that is happening you
know we're using references like Macario
um we wanted to like hone into the magic
realism that that exists in whatever the
treasure until a version of this
afterlife of how somebody can come in
and embrace this leap of faith in a way
that is reflective to the experience
that we wanted to portray with our
characters so that's when we say like
man I think that that has to go
um yeah uh talk a little bit about the
ending was it always the ending that we
see in the screen on screen or was there
ever another version of where the movie
was going to go so this was always the
ending but there was a time where
um
yesterday wanted to explore and anything
where
um
everything is like you know blowing up
and the booktube is going out
and the bug ship can't make it and Jaime
gives the extra push and saves the
family
um but I feel like I we felt like we've
seen that before
um
and and for me I really wanted all the
females in the story all the women in
his life to have a heroic Arc
I wanted them to I want to hide me on
his journey not to feel like
oh this is me saving my family from
Death I really wanted the whole thing to
feel like the family is hiding is saving
highness so that he can become the hero
he's supposed to become
um
and yes Jenny has her moment with
Victoria but with Jaime we wanted her to
like be the last hand and the push that
pushes him and the mom goes out and they
didn't need a superhero to save them
they saved themselves and they save the
superhero and that way uh keeping the
whole energy of like we can save
ourselves if we work together as opposed
to like we need somebody else to save us
now for the next movies we can do
whatever but for this one I really
wanted it to be everybody had a moment
everybody was saving Jaime protecting
her in the same way that our mothers
protect us
for us to be the people that we are
today so this is like a love letter to
those Patriarchs in our lives that
helped us become
heroes in our lives you know so you have
a very fun mid-credit scene uh talk a
little bit about how that ended up being
the mid-credit scene was it ever going
to be something else no that the whole
idea was we want to make criticism that
established the fact that death court is
alive
um
we want to not just to give closer to
the energy that we have established in
the movie about where is that chord
what's happened to the court he's
missing his dad you know
um we wanted to like say that the court
is out there we want to set up a
potential
um team up where we can continue with
the lore of Ted Court
or Booster Gold or anybody or one of
those guys coming in uh to Hyman's story
um but what what the the things that we
were definitely debating was like is he
gonna show up physically is is Booster
Gold gonna show up physically
um
so given the three regime changes that
we had in the making of this movie
um and probably their own willingness to
commit to something because maybe it
doesn't fit into somebody's Universe
um this was the Compromise that we
arrived to get like here's out there
he was able to cut into the the computer
and deliver that message and I think at
the end of the day it kind of like it
worked out it's pretty open uh to the
fact that we could eventually
um
you know have a Booster Gold and blue
hero thing happening you know one of
those things though
um how much like in your right like the
movie's about to come out and you really
don't know what's going to happen you
hope for the best but how much in your
brain are you sort of like man I really
am thinking about a sequel I am thinking
about where it can go and how much are
you sort of like pushing those things
out of your brain because you don't want
to jinx what could happen opening
weekend
um
well before I I knew that
sequels were depending on performance
um
you know that's they're not they're
naive in me
um me and the writers always saw this
movie As the First Act of a saga like we
always saw Jaime's story it doesn't end
on this first movie you know this first
movie literally is a first act like the
movie ends and now he can jump into the
new world right
um the movie ends and he still learning
how to use this he didn't fully
understand it
um the banter between him and kajira
was always evolving
in the story and we haven't had that
full interaction that we love from the
comics happen yet we wanted more of that
to get developed and and grow and and us
the audience and even the fans grow with
him in the other iterations as he goes
into like two or three so we wanted to
keep it self-contained we didn't want to
immediately have him team up with
anything those team-ups can happen
whenever they want to happen but in
hima's story this is just literally like
the beginning this is they just
connected then it comes like the whole
um relationship aspect of it which is
like the next version that we want to
explore and we're going to now that this
also is like a prologue of sorts that
sets up the stage of who is Jaime who is
his family you know his personality his
community now you don't have to spend
time exploring that and we want to give
this movie time to to really know uh to
give this introduction properly so that
we will know Jaime's heart fully so that
when the other movies come
um you know he can we can start having
explosions every five minutes if you
want but more importantly for me was uh
just being able to to to get invested on
on the family first make something
intimate
um make something more contained uh and
have the stakes be more personal than
World destroying Stakes that will come
like he will hopefully he'll fight the
reach you know uh eventually you know
when the rich ones take over the world
and they need to do it maybe
um but we want to take him step by step
I never I've never been fond of
you know I get the powers and 50 minutes
in and Swinging like nothing happened
and I'm saving the universe with no
experience I don't know I don't I don't
think that's
I don't know I cannot relate to that but
I can't relate to a kid who's trying to
who doesn't want this type of attention
uh because he's already drawing too much
attention for being Mexican in this
country so he doesn't want to do that
now he's a superhero with with World
destroying Powers you know that's a
thread but now he's understanding it and
now we're ready to witness his
transformation and to become the
superhero that we know he'll be I'm
curious how you chose your
cinematographer and I I don't know how
to pronounce uh Powell's last name is it
Powell Pavel yeah I can't pronounce the
last name so I'm not going to try but
how did you how did you pick how did you
decide on your cinematographer because
uh
it's an interesting choice
[Laughter]
so
I wanted to have a unique look I didn't
want to look like everything else that
we've done I and I'm a big fan of his
work
um from hereditary to mid-summer
um to nobody like I think he did an
amazing work with nobody also Beau is
afraid I'm always afraid I didn't
suppose afraid yet when I hired him
totally
um but I saw fresh that he also did and
and he's and he's very versatile like
all of those films are very different uh
visually
and and when we met just like same thing
with my VFX supervisor for example
um
they were very persistent and wanted to
do the movie mainly because they
connected to the story
his pole his polish
um and the script is a Mexican family
um he felt like this was his family this
felt like this was his story
he went through us you know he had lost
his dad and this meant so much to him
and he felt connected to the Reyes
family
uh and that type of
understanding an emotional level from an
artist is what I like to tap into same
thing with Bobby acrylic
um the composer
um who also did Midsummer I'm always
afraid I'm taking all aryasters guys
um
they they connected like we talked about
the story and they would cry about how
much it meant to them and that's the
type of
creative relationship that I like to
have uh when it's not just like yeah I
just want to kick ass and like that
doesn't do it for me you know at the end
of the day
even this is a superhero movie for me is
way more important the emotional stakes
and the emotional connection to have
with the characters
um that empathy that we can provoke with
Cinema and that's like the
like-mindedness that I found with these
collaborators so
but I was very open and he loved the
vision he loved the idea behind that and
I think it delivered I could dig in on
so many of the shots but I know I'm
going to run out of time so I'm going to
ask I'm going to get into probably the
most important thing we've we've talked
about it a little bit but the audience
probably has not heard it uh and that is
the Nintendo Power Glove
so for people that don't realize who are
young who do not know what the Nintendo
Power Glove is when you're missing out
right
um would you like to explain what it is
to people or should I give a little no
no so back in the early days of the do
you who knows what the Nintendo Power
Glove is okay exactly so basically it's
a device that came out with a Nintendo
NES long time ago if you were a kid it
was very expensive you're I only knew
one person that had it it had the
controller and the buttons on it and it
was really cool they also had the Fred
Savage movie uh which what does it what
was the name yeah exactly and uh anyway
it's a really cool thing from a long
time ago and you uh you know did an
homage to it in this movie yeah now we
so Ted cord you know we like to take
chord is from the 80s right he's in the
80s guy and and we always wanted him to
or the memory of him to to have gotten
stuck in that era
um and you know it was a as a as a guy
who tinkered with stuff and you know
because he couldn't uh hone the powers
of the Scarab he created technology you
know to replicate it and
given the way that Ted court is uh we
were like well what if you start
tinkering with the stuff that uh from
the 80s like uh you know the GPS is
again boy you know like why not like why
not think like back then you didn't have
like the technology like that but what
if you used
everyday objects or toys or Nintendo
Power gloves to create something cool uh
uh and that's because
my I had a cousin that had the Nintendo
glove and
and I he will never let me use it
um
and I always liked the idea that and
I've I wonder why but I always saw what
the stuff that he did and first like man
what if I could like use it for the
first time and slap him
and I we wanted to like incorporate it
into the story I was like well he
tinkered it and he was able to create
the Hologram out of it because that's
what my imagination was thinking at the
time uh you know this movie is like me
being 12 again and playing with real
people as toys and I were like yeah
let's have that moment and create that
inspiration because it's a very cool
device and like let's bring it back you
know
um and use it in this world and
because he's such a cool device and the
way it deploys and it happens to and the
way she uses it like she just [__]
slapped the guy
so that for us was really fun to use and
and again like just play a homage to to
our imaginations when we were kids you
know I saw the prop at the junket how
did you not keep that for yourself who
told you that I don't have one okay
no no we had a couple I think we broke
one
um yeah I think we broke one and that
was the one left so it's
been difficult to borrow it to yeah it's
been very difficult to what happened to
it disappeared
um
but I do have a one of those game boys
yeah which is cool like because the it
has the camera
like that device that gamble is like
this whole setup that it is a camera
that you can actually record 8-bit video
with it it's really cool what are the
things did you borrow from set
do you have one of the costumes
[Laughter]
we tried to lose that custom but that's
a very hard and expensive thing to lose
we're still I'm still wondering if I can
get a helmet I would love to get a
helmet I think that when uh if the movie
does well you should email James and
Peter and be like helmet just just a
helmet right that's just a helmet like
the one that cholo the one that that got
damaged because we used it like we used
like all the stunts are real and
all the Blue Beetle suits that you see
on the stunts are real Blue Beetle suits
that will smash against the ground like
we everything was like oh like cable
system uh style you know how many actual
of the because that's one of the reasons
it looks good on frame it's not a CGI
suit it's not CG yeah so how many of
those suits did you actually build and
do you actually know how much each one
costs like a roundabout so we did five
so 50 to 60k each I thought he said 30
to 50 but maybe I was wrong but the
first one
that was like uh
that was like a million or something
what what was it
[Music]
Young
now but the first one was expensive okay
I just want to go back real quick
because I saw a lot of people had hands
up for the Nintendo Power Glove I'm
going back to that who actually had one
when they were growing up or you just
knew what it was
right man they were so jealous like they
were so jealous of it I just want to
point out like so did anyone actually
have one in here
you have the Nintendo Power Glove
because this explains why we're also
like wanting one because I I only knew a
friend that had when it was too
expensive for me right I I I we I always
wanted to be like man what if we do like
the Nintendo collab and maybe a special
edition with one of those
never happened sequel sequel yeah it's
always yeah yeah I mean she kept it
she kept it
I read something and I could be very
wrong what I'm about to ask you and so
but I want to point out it could be very
wrong I read that you're actually
working on a Transformer spin-off movie
but this could be wrong is it right or
wrong no it's right that wasn't the
traits all right so let's talk about
this
uh what can you say
um
well I can say for a fact that Blue
Beetle comes out August 18th
and everybody should be there
Finance centered
that is the most important thing
obviously no but the other thing is like
um
uh did you let me ask you this did your
internet screens have a little bit I'll
start tomorrow
did you let me ask you because I'm gonna
I'm gonna try for something did you
pitch them an idea and they said oh
that's really good or was one of these
things similar to Blue Beetle where you
did a me you know what I mean my uh I
pushed them an idea and
they I read a script I
um
I didn't like it and
I pitched them a whole different idea
and they liked it but then it was too
late
so they told me uh yeah we cannot do
your idea
but
we like your idea so we want you to
write the idea and then direct it so
we're within that process but the writer
strike happened totally yeah
um yeah I'm so curious I'm gonna I'm so
curious you know what I mean so it's
it'll be it'll be different it'll be
different yeah well the thing about that
franchise and I know we're here for Blue
Beetle but the thing about that
franchise is that it's because when they
made the first one they never thought
they were going to make 22 of them so
it's so you know what I mean yeah you
gotta like have it fit in in the thing
except next summer they have that ilm
animated Transformers one which I've
heard is yeah everyone
that I've spoken to involved says it's
it's amazing yeah yeah that's what I
hear the same thing yeah from everyone I
mean number here is Transformers fan I'm
on a huge Ninja Turtle fan
um
so yeah I haven't seen the animated
Ninja Turtles but I can't wait I haven't
had the chance you promote again you
decide you love it there you go
yeah look at that everybody loves it
um on that note I'm going to say that
once we've gone into other subjects I'm
just gonna say man I'm really happy for
you and for people that are in the
audience here I just again wanna
thank you
um a huge thank you to IMAX huge thank
you to Warner Brothers and for all of
you in the audience
um please no spoilers but if you enjoyed
the movie and you use social media
perhaps you want to tag one of the
things that is up on the screen and
mention that you enjoyed the film yeah
if you like it make sure you share
something you know motivate people to go
support our actors like I want to see
more of them uh
I want to see more Blue Beetle of course
and if you didn't like the movie just
lie
it doesn't hurt you
you'll go to heaven I promise
on that note ladies and gentlemen thank
you for coming out here tonight and have
a fantastic night thank you